[música]
tienda
han sido durante mucho tiempo residentes del suroeste histórico
antiguas tierras rusas se llamaban a sí mismas
ruso y ortodoxo
gatos y
[música]
luego 12 kilómetros de perlas de vidrio se encuentran junto a bm
pashki y quienes son shawnee rublik
no esta claro gloria a ucrania
todo es claro diferente saludar
la palabra claro a
pero
entonces operador
de nuestros camaradas, parientes entre los cuales no se encuentran
solo colegas amigos ex colegas
pero también las personas familiares están conectadas desde navi
lazos familiares de sangre
bien hecho, molemos solo eso y
quería esperarte
atrapó nafs rusos en nuestro sótano
patio con ametralladoras con todo lo militar
panqueque timurov
¿Cómo es ella tan mala?
Las parejas de Ucrania pueden
fue por un tranvía apresurado profesional y gusto
Fiódorov
También quiero dar la calificación más alta.
acciones de soldados y oficiales rusos
actúan con valentía
profesionalmente
heroicamente
romper muchachos romper
puedes arrastrar de vuelta a Rusia y
come donde vas
tu tarea de unidad
conociste durante este tiempo a un antepasado
dobladores
[música]
contento de ucrania
para qué
aprobado
crees que me niego por diversión 5
puede funcionar sin problemas y decidió no esperar
mientras que 6 brut si follan el dia anterior
Yo lo protegeré hasta
y el tanque está abrumado, sí, esa es la rosa de Rusia
sokolov para una pareja
los niños serán útiles en el hogar
[música]
para jersey nosotros hasta que ella quiera ir y
aquí está martynyuk
como un fardo de mosquitos asustado
tres tanques y y y
así que mousse de piel o chicos, sois bielorrusos
que podrían volver a casa por veneno
quien es ucraniano te sugiero
dejar nuestras malditas armas hasta que
Vamos, no golpeas y presionas
es decir yo vivo aqui
Oh
[música]
aquí hay un olor
lo más probable es que shusha regrese
puerto deportivo malo en
las lluvias de ganso van al revés
manos estrecha ramadan y dejar su lugar
pantalones
de la gente